[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so sally bell
hatte gibt ein superschnelles blitz
rezept ich werde einen hin beiträgen zu
bereiten und waffeln ihr euch das
vorstellen wie eine art oft eins mit ihm
werden die in betten bereit ich zum
beispiel auf messen immer ganz gerne zu
und werde dort ebenfalls ein rezept
gefragt also gibt's heute das rezept und
ich zeige euch einfach mal kurz die
bluttaten für die hinweg brauche ich
drei eiweiß 70 gramm puderzucker und
hier habe ich noch 250 gramm
tiefgefrorene hin werden müsse
zuallererst die in bern fein pürieren
das heißt ich gehe nach hinten von mixa
kommt man kommt mit wenig draus
[Musik]
teil 1 ist nun schon fertig jetzt gebt
ihr einfach alle zutaten in einer
küchenmaschine das heißt allein das
eiweiß nicht ganz frisch sein dass es
ganz ausschließen oder zucker mir
schmeckt es am besten mit viel lernen
aber ihr könnt zum beispiel auch
erdbeeren verwenden oder andere die
meisten früchte auf den tiefkühlschrank
tiefkühlschrank ist ganz wichtig denn
ansonsten funktioniert es nicht und
jetzt fange ich an die creme auf
höchster geschwindigkeit zu berühren und
dann wird dir sowas gehört bisherige
schöne voluminös ist
[Musik]
jetzt ist ihm schon fertig und ihr seht
sie ist sehr gelungenes richtig groß
und genau so wie sie aussieht also
richtig schön locker und fruchtig
versteckten auch ich das einfach in
nantes herstellen
bei der krems quote könnte jetzt aber
nicht aufheben das heißt wenn ihr seht
in den kühlschrank gibt wird sie nach
wenigen minuten zusammenfallen könnte
was frisch machen und so gleich
operieren oder ihr könnt auch ein stehen
denn sie später nicht sondern die
kompetenz bleibt gleich aber sie wird
einfach ein bisschen kälter ich muss
dazu sagen ich mache die creme am
liebsten immer ganz frisch denn da
steckt ja weiß mit drin und das eiweiß
ist froh das heißt am besten frisch
zubereiten und verzehren
vor allem weil es einfach super schnell
und so einfach geht und ihr könnt ihr
auch die menge herunter registrieren auf
ein eiweiß dann habt ihr nicht eine
riesenportion ich möchte das ganze jetzt
hier an nachbars und freut sich auch
schon los
und jetzt kommt zu probieren ist ein
paar mal lecker also ich denke jeder der
die creme auf der messe schon mal
probiert hat kann jetzt einfach mal
einen kommentar hinterlassen
wie euch die creme geschmeckt hat denn
jetzt haben wir tausende zuschauer die
wir schon begonnen haben
superlecker echt lecker bequem auch nach
machen wollt geht auch tennis - roger
steht das rezept für euch und ich
wünsche euch jetzt schon mal ganz viel
spaß danach machen und bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]
verdreckt
feierabend